everything you need to know about what
has happened to the republican party
is perhaps best symbolized by lindsay
olin graham
this is a senator who spent all of 2015
and 2016
decrying donald trump he called him a
race-baiting
xenophobic religious bigot which is true
he said donald trump's plan on
immigration is stupid that's
also true and he said trump would be an
utter complete and total disaster
three adjectives that proved to be true
true
and true but then suddenly lindsey
graham
started praising the president sucking
up to him on the golf course
why of course you can have a mulligan
sir and defending him
on tv and in the senate and in due time
senator graham became chairman graham
taking control
of the senate judiciary committee in
time to lead that panel as it confirmed
two
of trump's highly controversial supreme
court nominees
and helped equip the president on
impeachment
maybe back then he was just afraid of
trump
so you might think graham owes trump
nothing now given
he was just re-elected with ease in
south carolina while trump
is on his way out a reality seen clearly
by
seemingly everyone but donald trump and
maybe though
also by lindsey graham who appears to be
breaking new ground
in what he's willing to do for this
president there is now a witness
who can back up a claim by the georgia
secretary of state
that senator graham asked brad
raffensberger whether he had the power
to reject certain ballots
graham asked him if ballots from a
certain county with a higher rate of
non-matching signatures could be thrown
out
which the secretary of state says he
interpreted as a suggestion
that he find a way to toss legal balance
that account has been confirmed by a
staff member to the secretary of state
who was listening in on that part of the
call
what i heard was basically discussions
about absentee ballots and if a
potentially if there was a percentage of
signatures that weren't
really truly matching is there some
point where you get to where you can say
somebody went to a courtroom could say
we'll sort out all these ballots because
we have no way of knowing because the
ballots are separated
senator graham though is shocked shocked
i tell you
at what the georgia secretary of state
is alleging against him
did you or did you not ask him to throw
out votes no
that's ridiculous i talked to him about
how you verify signatures
right now a single person verifies
signatures and i suggested
as you go forward can you change it to
make sure that a bipartisan team
verifies signatures and there's a
dispute come up with a field process
so he called his staff call saturday
trying to hook me up with a media outlet
so i could say something nice about him
i thought it was a nice conversation
look let's be clear brad raffersberger
is holding the line in georgia he is
trying to save
votes and thereby save democracy lindsey
graham on the other hand
who knows what he is up to but it
doesn't look good
joining me now to hopefully shed some
more light on all of that is the man at
the center of it all
georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger thank you so much for
joining me on the show
i want to talk about the election audit
in georgia in a moment and the
president's remarks
but let's just deal with this lindsey
graham conversation first
he denies asking you to toss out legally
cast ballots
but you have a witness your colleague
gabriel sterling who was on the call who
says he kind of did
so what on earth was is lindsey graham
playing at in your view
well when he reached out to her office i
thought he was wanting to call and
want us to talk about the senator the
senate runoff
election but immediately really asked
about
our absentee ballot process so i went
through and explained
that with your signature match we do
that during the application
and we also then do it uh as the ballots
come back in
it's done signature match and we've uh
now strengthened it so that we have
georgia bureau of investigation uh
trained
signature matchers they they've been
trained with their election officials
but uh you want to know if it could be
once they've been approved and they've
been separated
could you match those back to the
envelope and i said no you can't because
they've not been separated so you have
the secret ballot
and then i felt that he implied that for
us to audit the envelopes and
then throw out the ballots of counties
who had the highest frequency
error rate of signatures and so
we got off the call
or me sorry i was going to say
he implied just to be clear he was
suggesting that you should throw out
legally cast ballots just to confirm
that
well that was that was my implication is
that what you know uh if people bring a
bias
uh he talked about that if they're in
certain counties they have a bias to
accept
ballots or a bias to not accept ballots
and how would you know and if you if you
start seeing that there are a few then
what would there be a case that you
could just you know get rid of all of
them and i said no you can't do
that and you can't tie this back anyway
because they've been separated you know
how people voted
at that time and
you say uh you spoke with legal counsel
who advised you not to call him back
do you believe lindsey graham possibly
broke the law by making the request to
you that you suggest he made
uh he was exploring options and i'm not
an attorney i just didn't call him back
it's just a road that i was going to go
down on i
thought we were going to talk you know
one i guess i thought he was going to
have
one some input on what i thought the uh
off race
for the senators looked like uh and it
was something totally different so
it just was something you know we're
making sure that uh
you know we follow the process of all
the law uh we have signature match
in fact uh when i got here as secretary
of state in 2019 we outlawed bella
harvesting for absentee ballots
uh we uh started photo id this year with
our online ballot portal so we have very
strong
uh guardrails in georgia
you suggest you say you're not a lawyer
fair enough uh so forget whether it was
legal or not
you say something it was something was
it something inappropriate
in your view i just felt that uh
we have been getting enough pressure
enough anger uh voice status from all
sides and
at the end of the day i just want to
make sure that we follow the law
we follow the process and we're going to
count the ballots and that's why we're
doing 100
audit we're recounting retelling every
single ballot that has been cast
so we can verify before we certify you
know what the
total vote count is and already we found
in a couple counties
that there were some discrepancies and
they went to president trump's uh
benefit he's uh instead 14 000 he's
about 12 000
ballots there and and that's what we
want to do is make sure we can verify
the council everyone has 100
confidence in the result of this
election
rudy giuliani has taken over the trump
legal effort and was in court today
claiming
widespread nationwide voter fraud your
election officials as you mentioned a
moment ago have now uncovered
i think more than 5 000 uncounted votes
in floyd and fayette counties
i believe you're also looking at walton
county as well the president tonight
keeps talking about dead voters in your
state
but has your audit your investigation
uncovered
actual evidence of quote widespread
voter fraud in the state of georgia
we've not found widespread voter fraud
we have obviously
always some double voting we had about
four people voted twice
um and so we've identified that uh we've
checked for felons voting that are still
under sentence
and then we look for any other people
that have already
deceased obviously you try and catch
everything
and some of that goes to we're trying to
make sure our voter rolls
and we have list maintenance that's
updated but we are restricted by federal
law
but from a georgia perspective just to
be clear it is inaccurate it is a lie
for donald trump and rudy giuliani to
say
there is widespread nationwide voter
fraud
it is inaccurate to say that there's
widespread voter fraud in the state of
georgia
that's correct let's talk about the
president who has gone from endorsing
you as a fantastic candidate in 2018
to now attacking you and calling you a
republican in name only a rhino
republican
he's referred to your recount as a scam
what is your response to the president
what is your message to him tonight
i've been a conservative all my life
just ask my family ask my kids
and then just look at my voting records
i've always been pro tax payer making
sure that we can
reduce tax burdens whenever we can i'm a
small business owner
i understand how tough it is to make you
know make a dollar and go
and provide for your workers and make
sure that you can you have a company
that's successful
uh so i don't have to do any explaining
on that
but that's why we do have in state law i
have an audit
and we're doing a wristling audit
instead of doing 90 confidence level or
95 we're doing 100
that means we're counting every single
ballot all 5 million ballots
again and we're counting them by hand
because people have been throwing
dispersions about the accuracy of the
electronic count
and what we're seeing is that some
counties are have
no difference at all
isn't the president by attacking you
personally by attacking the vote by
attacking the software
isn't he undermining confidence in
democracy in georgia not just nationwide
but specifically in your state
undermining confidence in the vote
and the eventual result well
uh to be fair it cuts both ways stacey
abrams lost fair and square by 53 000
votes and she didn't accept her loss
and likewise now we have new voting
machines with a verifiable paper ballot
trail
so we're going to do this audit we're
going to verify the results
and at the end of the day people are
going to have to say that's it i don't
like it and i get that half the people
won't like the results the other half
will be ecstatic i get it
i'm probably going to be the half that
doesn't like these results i'm a
republican
but it doesn't look like the president
but there's a difference isn't there
secretary of state between
liking the result not liking the result
that's part and parcel of democracy
but saying the result is not legitimate
it's a scam as the president is
suggesting
what is your response to that to the
president's specific allegations
uh as my accountant always says the
numbers never lie
and as we do 100 recount of these
numbers
they're going to be true and theirs will
be the correct numbers and that's what
we're going to certify
and i think it's going to show that the
president trump came up short
came up short he won't be happy to hear
that and it's not just this republican
president attacking you george's two
republican senators
have called on you to resign some people
are calling you i saw a headline earlier
today the most hated republican in the
party
did you know when you took this stance
of defending the election defending your
work
that it might cost you your career in
the republican party do you have any
regrets about that oh not at all
uh you know i've been a business owner
for years i'm here to really to do the
will of the people
i was on city council i wanted to you
know push for uh
really making our city a better place
when i was in the state house looking
what's best for georgia what's best for
my district
as secretary of state i want to make
sure we brought in new voting machines
that we also made sure that we could do
list maintenance and we could outlaw
ballot harvesting
now uh we also have like business
licensing and we'll work on
licensing reform i think we have too
many boards and uh i think that we can
streamline that and really help
the people that are have professional
licensing
is it true that you and your family have
been subjected to death threats too in
recent days
uh yes specifically my wife has gotten
most of threats i guess they don't uh
send those directly to me but my wife
has gotten those and uh
we received we forward those on to
authorities but it's uh
very upsetting it's um it's pretty
disgusting when it's your own party
doing that
it is pretty disgusting and i'm so sorry
to hear that's happening to you and your
wife
uh you mentioned you know your own party
doing that i want to ask
we know who's doing it in terms of
sending you threats people who are angry
about the idea of donald trump losing
but who's responsible for inciting that
kind of disgusting behavior to quote
your
description well
it's people that are really spinning up
the crowd and
not even speaking truth they're not
speaking truth about the
results are not speaking truth about the
voting equipment at the end of the day
you know if i wanted to i've been in the
construction business for 40 years
i could use my what i call contractor
language and you know and scream and
holler and bellow and things like that
but i think nowadays today what we need
are people that are just going to speak
truth and and handle you know the
situation and be civil to each other
it's one thing i learned in the general
assembly i sat next to a democrat on
each side
and we would talk about bills and they
didn't maybe win me to their side and i
didn't want them to their side at least
we had conversations and i think we need
to be more civil with each other
uh not sure the president agrees on that
but it's interesting you said it's
people spinning people up against you
you didn't name the people but it's very
clear those people are donald trump
and kelly lafleur and david perdue and
other republican officials
inciting against you that's clear isn't
it
well at the end of the day i don't want
to play with people's emotions
i'm here to do a job i'm an engineer and
i just want to look at what is the
process
and where where the numbers shake out at
the end of the day and i'm going to
leave the rest
they have to you know lead their lives
and we're going around our office with
integrity
i think integrity still matters
one last question do you think if donald
trump hadn't spent much of the year
undermining mail-in voting and
dissuading his voters from mailing in
their ballots rather than staying at
home
he could have actually won a swing state
like yours fair and square
is he perhaps the author of his own
electoral demise
i believe so because the numbers show
that there were actually 24 000
republican voters that voted absentee in
the june primary
and those same 24 000 voters did not
show up to vote
in either absentee or in person on the
day of election or the 15 days of early
voting we have
so they just disappeared and they were
right for the picking they were there
in june for the primary and they should
have come home and and voted for
president trump in the fall so that's 24
000.
that's his difference right there
secretary of state brad raffensberger
thank you so much for your time
another way lindsey graham is
downplaying his
questionable behavior in georgia is by
saying
he's done the same in other states
i've talked to doug ducey in arizona
i've talked to the people in nevada
we've got contests all over the nation
the thing is arizona republican governor
doug ducey isn't in charge of elections
in that state that responsibility falls
to secretary of state katie hobbs
a democrat who said earlier today that
graham had not reached out to her
and nevada's secretary of state put out
a similar statement today
whoever graham talked to in those states
it wasn't the ultimate deciders
so for more on this arizona secretary of
state katie hobbs joins me now
thank you so much uh for coming on the
show lindsey graham says he spoke to
arizona governor doug ducey
about the vote in arizona why do you
think he didn't call you you're in
charge of that
and also what has governor duty told you
about what was said between them
well i can't begin to speculate on uh
senator graham's motives or what he
what his purpose of is in terms of
interfering in other states elections
and i have not talked to the governor
about his conversation with the senator
if lindsey graham had called you
personally to ask about non-matching
signatures on mail-in ballots for
example and the possibility
of excluding them what would you have
told him i would have told him that the
election
procedures in arizona are first of all
none of his business
and second of all that we have statutes
in place that were complied with
throughout the entire process of this
election there have been no
widespread irregularities or fraud and
claims to the contrary are just simply
false
what do you make of the fact that graham
is only making these calls to states
where trump
lost and not say north carolina where he
won a tight race
uh with a million mail-in ballots cast
funny that
well yeah it is i don't again know what
his motives are
but um i will say this again i don't
think
uh elected officials from other states
have any business
questioning the election process in in
other states
uh it's been clear throughout this
process that elected officials in our
own state don't even understand
how this works and they've all they've
done is contributed to muddying the
waters
undermining confidence in the election
and making our
jobs as election officials harder
based on what brad raffenberger says is
what lindsey graham did possibly illegal
should he have to
at least resign a senate judiciary
chairman given what he's being accused
of
well i think that is up to the senate
ethics committee
um i don't know the laws in georgia but
it sounds like
he was asking for legally cast ballots
to be thrown out
and that is highly questionable uh
behavior
and since we're talking about highly
questionable behavior rudy giuliani is
now almost all that's left of trump's
legal team in pennsylvania where he just
filed
a new brief with a court in williamsport
this comes after he humiliated himself
for four seasons total landscaping in
philadelphia
since then he's claimed the democrat
machine in philly detroit atlanta
chicago
rigged the election uh he says there's
four there's fraud by a quote foreign
company
uh pick to count the vote and that biden
supporters riot because they're lawless
all of these of course are malicious
lies i do wonder though how worried
concerned would you be
if giuliani tomorrow turns up in your
state with a bunch of new lawsuits
well again um they don't have evidence
for any of the lawsuits that have been
brought in the state of arizona
um there's two remaining challenges that
are not
uh on behalf of the trump campaign
they're on behalf of the state
republican party
um and there's really no merit to their
claims
uh so i mean i think we've seen that
they're gonna continue to throw out
these
um allegations uh until
i don't know when uh until i guess we
certify the results
uh but we are on track to certify the
state's election results on november
30th that's what we plan to do
and um you know there's really there
there's no basis for the claims that
they're making
and i i can't necessarily speak to other
states but in arizona for certain um
there there's really no legal claims
left for them to make
so just to follow up on that you know
given there's no legal basis
and given this is basically all that's
left of trump's legal
election team now a bunch of conspiracy
theorists really
uh the president has lost i think most
of the major law firms that were
representing him
do you think trump's heart is in this
legal fight or is it all just for show
well i mean we've seen the president for
months and months and months prior to
the election
already working to invalidate the
results of the election so we knew that
these kind of legal fights were coming
he's still on twitter you know making
all these false claims
um again i don't want to ascribe motives
to somebody but
he the only way he has to come out of
this
is to continue to claim that the
election was stolen
and i hope it ends soon because we are
you know
my office has been bombarded with calls
we've had to reroute calls to voicemail
so that my staff are not getting
harassed
by callers um i've been threatened my
family's been threatened
um and it would be really nice if these
uh elected leaders
would stand up and say stop the stop
the allegations our election system is
just fine here in arizona
and and and just to check uh you know
i just spoke to georgia secretary of
state who said that he's got death
threats as well did you ever think being
an election official would result in
death threats
isn't that outrageous and kind of
unprecedented
i mean i've been an elected official in
arizona for a while
uh i've seen the climate i understand
the climate
um so this is certainly not unexpected
but i do think it's uncalled for and i
think if
we didn't have elected leaders that were
fueling these conspiracies
that it would help to
tamper some of the threatening behavior
that we've seen here
and mail in voting in your state you
have a long history of mail-in voting
that all held up this time around there
were no issues
oh absolutely it worked it worked the
way it was supposed to
we saw unprecedented turnout both in
person
and in early voting by mail and we've
had a long track record of it working
well in the states so
there were no issues uh this year
katie hobbs thank you so much for your
time we'll have to leave it there